[Applause]  irving two second different shot clocked  the game clock spurs have to make a  decision here  irving playing keep away drive irving  ball fake scoops it up  no good four seconds left  murray loses the basketball fires it up  oh it's good count it we are tied  and going overtime in san antonio  a last-second prayer from dejante murray  and what a possession for this first  trigger for replays to see if the field  goal is released  prior to the exploration of the game  used up enough time  was doing an excellent job with  the time management and doesn't go in  quick push dejante murray losing control  here and trying to figure out where he's  going to go with  shoots it up as the clock is winding  down  disjointed play